euh le Haut Conseil pour le climat donc
est pour rappel parce que on a déjà fait
des interventions dans cette commission
je vous remercie c'est un organisme
neutre et indépendant qui a pour mission
principale d'évaluer l'action publique
en matière de climat y compris la
trajectoire de baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre les plus de carbone
l'emprunte carbone l'adaptation au
changement climatique et aussi de jeter
un regard sur les impacts
socio-économiques des actions
climatiques le Haut Conseil mais en
perspective l'action de la France par
rapport à celle des autres pays il
recommande des actions et ce qui fait
l'unique l'originalité du Haut Conseil
pour le climat c'est que le gouvernement
doit présenter une réponse ou
recommandations du Haut Conseil pour le
climat au Parlement et au seaser donc à
vous les députés
six mois après les recommandations après
le après la publication de son rapport
annuel et c'est ce cycle de rapport
réponse rapport et réponse qui se veut
être un cycle amplificateur de l'action
climatique
dans son rapport 2023 le Haut Conseil
pour le climat a d'abord revu la façon
dont la France gère les éléments
météorologiques et climatiques qu'il a
touche dans la perspective de à l'avenir
évaluer sa politique d'adaptation
conformément au mandat qui lui est donné
les l'année 2022 donc
a été emblématique de l'intensification
des effets du changement climatique
c'est une année record l'année 2022 on a
encore battu des records dans les
derniers mois mais l'année 2022 dans
l'ensemble a été exceptionnellement
chaude avec 2,9 degrés de réchauffement
de température moyenne en France trois
vagues de chaleur un déficit de
précipitation important en France
métropolitaine alors que les outre-mer
tropicaux ont enregistré de fortes
précipitations à l'inverse avec
d'importantes inondations ces événements
s'inscrivent dans une trajectoire de
réchauffement du aux activités humaines
certains aspects ont été exceptionnels
on est surpris pourquoi est-on encore
surpris de l'intensité des événements
climatiques qui s'inscrivent dans la
trajectoire de de réchauffement
climatique on ne devrait plus en 2022
être surpris
ces événements de 2022 donc ont eu des
impacts graves sur les personnes sur les
activités économiques sur les
infrastructures et sur les écosystèmes
les dispositifs de prévention et de
gestion de crise n'ont pas permis
d'éviter toutes les conséquences des
événements de 2022 il y a quelques
exemples à l'écran plus de 2000 communes
ont connu de fortes tensions pour
s'approvisionner en eau potable pointant
les limites du dispositif de gestion de
l'eau actuelle et ce malgré une révision
qui a été fait en 2021 en réponse au
retour d'expérience des sécheresses
précédentes donc on n'a pas appris ou en
tout cas pas appris suffisamment des
événements précédents on est encore dans
la réponse réactive 8000 communes ont
fait des demandes pour reconnaissance de
catastrophes naturelles à cause de
dommages ou bâtiments causés par les
effets de RET rait gonflement des
argiles dus à la sécheresse des sols
c'est dommage on induit un coup seul
c'est dommage on réduit un coup de 2,9
milliards pour les assurances en 2022 9
milliards
et là aussi on voit bien
l'empreinte du réchauffement climatique
derrière ces changements comme vous le
savez
72000 hectares ont brûlé l'année
dernière excédant les limites des moyens
français de lutte contre les incendies
de végétations des moyens étrangers ont
dû être déployés en renfort les vagues
de chaleur et estivales ont induit plus
de 2800 décès en excès malgré un
dispositif sanitaire éprouvé depuis 2004
on sait gérer les vagues de chaleur et
malgré cela on a quand même 2800 décès
la sécheresse des sols exceptionnelles a
touché trois quarts du territoire
métropolitain le rendement agricole
abaissé de 10 à 30% pour certaines
filières et la production
hydroélectrique a diminué de 20%
. ces impacts ont donc nécessité des
mesures d'urgence et d'indemnisation qui
ont atteint voir excéder les capacités
de gestion des services
le réchauffement est amplifié en France
par rapport au niveau mondial
le plus de degrés de réchauffement à
l'horizon 2030
et pratiquement inévitable en France
avec des années extrêmes comment 2022
qui vont devenir de plus en plus
fréquentes et qui vont encore
s'intensifier la température record en
2022 elle serait la température moyenne
à l'horizon 2050 2060 pour un
réchauffement planétaire qui atteindrait
2 degrés
après 2050 l'emprun l'ampleur du
réchauffement dépend des émissions
futures sur la base des politiques
actuelles 4 degrés de réchauffement en
France est projeté vers 2100 avec des
années plus extrêmement encore
aujourd'hui l'adaptation se fait
largement en mode réactif mais ceci ne
suffit pas comme on l'a vu à prévenir
les impacts futurs et il est probable
que l'équilibre du système assurantiel
en France ne tiendra pas dans sa
configuration actuelle
l'adaptation doit donc devenir
antispatrice préventive transformatrice
et bien sûr changer d'échelle le cadre
de référence qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement de s'adapter suivant une
trajectoire de réchauffement de 4 degrés
en France et cohérent avec les
connaissances scientifiques à condition
de prendre en compte les risques
supplémentaires qui sont de plusieurs
natures soit la variété naturelle qui se
superpose et fait que des années comme
2022 amplifient le réchauffement de
manière plus ponctuelle mais aussi les
risques de renversement des politiques
climatiques au niveau mondial qui sont
très très réels et ce liées bien sûr aux
incertitudes sur les connaissances de la
réponse du climat et du cycle du carbone
en ce qui concerne le constat sur
l'évaluation l'évolution des gaz à effet
de serre donc une baisse rapide des
émissions et donc plus que jamais
essentiel pour contenir
l'intensification des risques
climatiques graves la baisse en France
des émissions elle se poursuit on a vu
en 2022 une baisse de 2,7% pour les
émissions brutes sans tenir compte des
puits de carbone soit 11 millions de
tonnes d'équivalence CO2 vous avez
peut-être vu aujourd'hui les annonces de
la cité pas sur la baisse des émissions
de plus de 4% 4,5%, je pense sur la
première moitié de l'année ça s'inscrit
aussi dans cette poursuite
donc la baisse en 2022 elle est due à
une forte baisse dans le secteur du
bâtiment et de l'industrie qui
s'explique en partie par un hiver très
doux qui a réduit la demande de
chauffage mais aussi par les mesures de
sobriété prises en réponse à la hausse
des prix de l'énergie et aux appels à la
sobriété du gouvernement cette baisse a
en partie été compensée par une hausse
des émissions dans les secteurs des
transports qui continuent qui ont
continué leur bon poste vide et dans le
secteur de l'énergie due à
l'indisponibilité du parc nucléaire non
programmé et à la baisse de la
production hydroélectrique
dû aux conditions climatiques
exceptionnellement sèches
la loi climat hérésilience de 2019 a
établi des budgets carbone c'est ce
qu'on voit là donc vous voyez du coup la
trajectoire des émissions dans le passé
la trajectoire projetée dans la loi
actuelle et les budgets carbone actuels
dans la loi
et donc ces budgets carbone sont
inscrits dans la loi leur niveau par
décret et ce sont des seuils à ne pas
dépasser sur les années correspondant à
la deuxième au deuxième budget carbone
donc qui se trouve à être juste ici
les le budget carbone pour les émissions
brutes donc sans tenir compte de
l'absorption début de carbone est en
voie d'être respectée c'est ce que vous
voyez ici donc la ligne noire observée
elle est sous la barre verte
en partie à cause de la baisse des
émissions dues aux restrictions imposées
durant la pandémie par contre pour en ce
qui concerne les émissions nettes avec
plus de carbone et on pourra aller plus
en détail lors des questions le budget
est en moi d'être dépassé car les puits
de carbone sur tous les forêts ont
beaucoup diminué à cause de la forte
mortalité d'une croissance des arbres
trop faibles et de prélèvements en plus
des feux de forêt en 2022
les rythmes de baisse actuelle sont
insuffisants pour atteindre les
objectifs de 2030 et doivent presque
doubler la baisse observée pour les
émissions brutes que vous voyez ici
9,1 millions de tonnes sur les trois
dernières années la baisse attendue par
la stratégie nationale bacarbonate
actuelle donc avec un objectif de -40%
en 2030 elle est de 12 millions de
tonnes sur cette période en moyenne en
par année donc on n'est pas encore à cet
objectif de plus bien sûr l'objectif
2030 a été renforcée en 2021 par la loi
européenne sur le climat et cet objectif
décliné pour la France qui est pas
encore inscrit dans la loi mais qui a
été annoncé implique une baisse de 17
millions de tonnes de CO2 en moyenne sur
cette période donc vous voyez le nouvel
objectif pour européen pour la France et
c'est le point jaune là
donc le rythme de baisse des émissions
doit presque doubler et les puits de
carbone doivent en parallèle fortement
augmenté alors qui diminuent à l'heure
actuelle donc cette baisse là au niveau
national elle doit être
répartie entre les différents secteurs
émetteurs et c'est bien les choix du
gouvernement qui vont distribuer ces
efforts entre secteurs pour les secteurs
qui ne sont pas couverts par le système
d'échange de quotas d'émission
européenne
donc au hsec nous a en fait deux
hypothèses pour cette répartition soit
une répartition dans la configuration
actuelle donc avec la distribution de
l'effort actuel et une répartition égale
entre secteurs selon leur poids en
émission dans les deux cas les rythmes
de baisse que vous voyez ici dans
l'encadré en bas les rythmes de baisse
des émissions doivent être reussés pour
l'ensemble des secteurs sauf pour le
secteur du bâtiment où on a une marge de
manœuvre pour les secteurs des
transports et de l'énergie la hausse est
forte avec un facteur 3,5 à 5 comparé à
leur baisse depuis 2019
dans le secteur de l'agriculture les
choix du gouvernement auront une finance
majeure
parce que selon le choix que l'on fait
le facteur amplificateur pourrait être
de 1,25 ou 3,5 si on distribue les
efforts de manière équitable entre
secteur ou de manière proportionnelle
entre secteur
cependant la baisse constater des puits
de carbone implique que des efforts
supplémentaires dans le secteur
agriculture agricole seront nécessaires
afin d'augmenter le stockage de carbone
dans les sols
l'industrie doit aussi son rythme de
baisse par un facteur 1,4 à 1,6 et en ce
qui concerne les émissions du bâtiment
ce sont les seuls qui pour le moment
respectent le rythme de baisse pour
lequel le rythme de baisse est
compatible avec le rythme attendu en
2030 bien que du coup lorsque l'on
regarde l'analyse sous-jacente elle
montre que le nombre de rénovations
énergétiques profonde et bien inférieur
au nombre nécessaire pour aller jusqu'à
la neutralité carbone en 2050
pour le constat sur l'avancée le des
politiques publiques
le Haut Conseil pour le climat a
développé cette année une nouvelle
méthode d'évaluation qui a permis de
montrer de nombreux blocages
la période de la méthode d'évaluation
est inclut l'appréciation du cadre
public sous 5 axes que nous avons
appliqué cette année sous mot de réduit
mais je vous donne les conclusions que
nous avons pu tirer cette année de cette
analyse
pour le volet stratégie qui est le mieux
développé de nombreuses documents
stratégiques et plan d'actions ont été
publiés ils sont généralement bien
cadrés avec des priorités et des actions
et ils mobilisent les parties prenantes
la cohérence et l'alignement des
stratégies avec les objectifs
climatiques par ailleurs ne sont pas
assurés et les dispositifs de suivi et
d'évaluation sont souvent incomplets ce
qui rend difficile la garantie de
l'atteinte des objectifs
surtout pour le deuxième volet
d'évaluation la stratégie n'est pas
alors actuelle accompagnée d'une
politique économique d'ampleur
permettant de déclencher l'accélération
nécessaire
l'examen des politiques pour les sous
secteurs des voitures et des logements
montrent l'existence de paquets de
mesures mais les incitations et les
moyens financiers qui les accompagnent
sont insuffisants un soutien public
supplémentaire est nécessaire qui doit
augmenter avec le temps pour atteindre
environ 30 milliards par an en 2030 tous
secteurs confondus pour la part publique
soit la moitié des financements publics
et privés nécessaires selon le rapport
Pisani ferry mafouze qui a été publiée
plutôt dans l'année
la politique économique de la France
doit donc être transformé afin de
permettre d'atteindre les rythmes de
baisse des émissions attendues et de
mettre en place une adaptation
transformationnelle ceci comprend la
politique budgétaire fiscale commerciale
industriel et celles de l'emploi une
trajectoire de financement aussi jusqu'à
l'atteinte de la neutralité carbone ceci
comprend une trajectoire depression des
dépenses et des niches fiscales
défavorables au climat et la
structuration et la création de
nouvelles filières de la transition
énergétique
pour le troisième volet les freins et
leviers de la transition donc ici on
entend compétences infrastructures
organisation des marchés etc ils sont
nombreux par exemple 15 freins et
leviers ont été
identifiés pour le seul secteur des
transports ceci donne une idée de
l'ampleur du travail à accomplir ces
freins et leviers du coup dans
l'approche du gouvernement ou dans
l'approche de l'État sont généralement
identifiés mais ils ne sont souvent pas
traités de manière systématique dans la
durée
quatrième volet la contribution de
l'adaptation au respect des budgets
carbone n'est pas explicite dans le
cadre existant avec l'agriculture et les
puits de carbone qui sont les mieux
couverts et les risques de l'adaptation
sont du coup à l'heure actuelle peu
identifier dernier volet les politiques
climatiques pèsent davantage sur les
ménages modestes malgré les efforts qui
sont faits en Gibles pour compenser les
effets et régressifs ceci s'explique par
une offre inadéquate par exemple les
offres de véhicules doivent être petits
légers pour être abordables et par les
limites de capacité de réponse des
ménages qui s'ajoutent à un contexte de
forte inflation
au niveau à l'international la
multiplication des politiques publiques
commencent à faire réfléchir les
émissions mondiales
au moins 18 pays dont la France voit
leurs émissions et leur empreinte
carbone diminué depuis une dessinée ou
plus avec plus de 3000 lois climatiques
nationales qui ont permis d'éviter
plusieurs milliards de tonnes
d'équivalence CO2 au niveau mondial les
engagements actuels malgré tout ne
suffisent pas à limiter le réchauffement
dans la fourchette 1,5 à 2 degrés et le
plus près possible des 1,5 degrés alors
que la Coop 27 de l'année dernière n'a
pas permis d'avancer sur les engagements
de réduction des missions
l'adoption de la majorité des textes du
fit for fifty-five au niveau européen
viennent structurer l'action de l'Europe
et de la France ce développement positif
clarifie comment l'Union européenne
compte atteignent ces objectifs de 2030
ces textes doivent être rapidement
doivent rapidement se traduire en mesure
concrète avec plein d'investissement
déclinés sur le long terme et
l'évolution des dispositifs qui les
accompagnent à la fois au niveau
européen et au sein des États membres y
compris la France avance du coup à un
rythme qui est encore difficilement
compatible avec les objectifs 2030 dans
7 ans
dans l'optique du besoin de relancer la
dynamique internationale la France doit
préparer une position forte en amont de
la cop28 sur la base du renforcement de
ses objectifs rehaussés de 2030
pour le constat il est grand temps du
coup
dacté l'urgence et d'engager les moyens
nécessaires ou rehaussement de l'action
publique en matière d'adaptation de
transformationnelle et de décarbonation
accélérée en France et dans le monde
l'année 2022 a révélé les limites
capacitaires de gestion de crise en
France et faire ressortir que plus que
jamais plus que jamais le besoin de
définir une politique économique
d'ampleur permettant de déclencher
l'accélération nécessaire
tout en atteignant les objectifs de
neutralité car moi en 2050 bien sûr la
loi ne programmation quinquennale sur
l'énergie et le climat à elpek la
révision de la stratégie nationale bas
carbone et la stratégie française pour
l'énergie et le climat sont des périodes
d'opportunité à ne pas rater pour
concrétiser système systématisé et
opérationnaliser les nouveaux objectifs
en conclusion
les principales conclusions de notre
rapport sont les suivantes l'adaptation
en mode réactif et ponctuel qui est
prévalant aujourd'hui ne suffit pas
l'adaptation doit changer d'échelle le
cadre stratégique qui se construit doit
être mise en oeuvre de manière
opérationnelle et systématique il doit
être accompagné d'une politique
économique d'ampleur alors que la
dynamiques internationale elle doit être
relancée en amont de la cop28 le Haut
Conseil pour le climat a fait plus de
100 recommandations spécifiques qui
viennent accompagner ses conclusions
elles sont disponibles dans un petit
pamphlet devant la salle avec le résumé
exécutif maintenant la réponse du
gouvernement assez recommandations est
attendue d'ici la fin de l'année
conformément à la loi énergie et climat
et cette réponse se fait bien sûr au
Parlement et aux œufs je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente pour ce
pompon introductif nous en venant aux
orateurs des groupes et pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Marjolaine
ménilfer
si monsieur le Président chers
Mondon madame Guillaume merci pour votre
présence aujourd'hui en premier lieu je
voulais saluer au nom du groupe
Renaissance votre tabac ainsi que ceux
de vos équipes pour la richesse du
contenu scientifique et l'effort
pédagogique que vous déployez pour le
rendre accessible à tous merci pour ça
parce que votre travail est précieux et
nous le suivons ici avec beaucoup
d'attention l'édition 2023 de votre
rapport donc paru en juin appelle les
pouvoirs publics à entrer dans une phase
plus proactive marquée par une volonté
de préparer l'adaptation et de piloter
la planification ces deux appels nous
semblent avoir été d'ores et déjà
entendu au moins en partie par le
gouvernement avec la présentation du
travail du sgpe en juillet ça doit vous
rassurer d'ores et déjà de même que
l'augmentation significative des budgets
pour le PDF dédié à la transition
écologique ainsi que les travaux qui ont
été menés autour de l'adaptation à une
France plus 4 degrés qui ont été eux
lancés c'était en mai c'est ma mémoire
est bonne donc tout ça ultérieur à votre
rapport tout ça est-ce que vous l'avez
suivi est-ce que ça vous semble déjà un
peu plus à la hauteur
dans un second temps je voudrais
m'attarder sur l'appropriation par les
territoires et les Français des enjeux
de la planification écologique je sais
qu'à vous tient à cœur madame la
Présidente il y a des réticences fortes
encore dans les territoires et chez
locaux citoyens qu'est-ce que vous
aimeriez répondre à ce président de
région qui annonce vouloir se retirer du
dispositif 0 artificialisation nette ou
encore aux propriétaires bailleurs qui
voudraient repousser les chances de
rénovation des passoires thermiques
comment on peut lutter contre ces
réticences quel rôle pour les
collectivités territoriales dans la
planification
quelle vigilance vous aurez par la
déclinaison des objectifs de
planification dans les stradettes vous
les avez mentionnés dans votre
PowerPoint que pensez-vous de l'annonce
de la première ministre de mettre sur
pied des coffres régionales chargés
selon ses mots de faire converger
travaux nationaux et remonter des
territoires parce que les régions sont
les chefs de fil de l'aménagement du
territoire l'échelon pour la réflexion
stratégique et la planification ce mode
de gouvernance vous paraît-il pertinent
et comment souhaiteriez-vous y être
associé je vous remercie
rassemblement national la parole est à
Pierre meringue
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame monsieur chers
collègues
enliminaire en introduction je voudrais
rappeler que la France aimait 0,9% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre au
niveau mondial et que nous sommes par
ailleurs les bons élèves de nous étions
les bons élèves de la décarbonation
notamment grâce à notre énergie
nucléaire l'arbre largement abîmée c'est
30 dernières années je m'en inquiétude
est aussi celle-ci c'est que
l'industrialisation des pays en voie de
développement
qu'on pense en termes de gaz à effet de
serre l'ensemble des efforts que nous
pouvons nous faire français il faut
faire des efforts mais il manque il
manque une corde à votre arc c'est que
51% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de notre pays proviennent de nos
importations qu'est-ce que vous pensez
donc de l'idée de relocaliser la
production en France retisser un
maillage de services publics
français des logements à bas coût pour
les Français les plus modestes question
dernière quand allez-vous cesser de
préconiser au nom de la transition
écologique des mesures technocratiques
et injustes pour nos concitoyens les
plus modestes pour le groupe la France
insoumise nups la parole est à Sylvain
carrière
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente dans votre présentation du
rapport annuel de juin dernier vous
présentiez l'échec de la politique
climatique menée aujourd'hui en France
le rythme de réduction des missions des
gaz à effet de serre doit doubler
annuellement pour tenir les objectifs
européens du feed forfait site
fifty-five les objectifs pourraient
arriver sont détaillés dans votre
excellent rapport et pourtant le
gouvernement sous couvert de
planification écologiques que l'on
pourrait appeler greenwashing d'État
nous embarque dans sa bagnole qui fonce
droit dans le mur prenons l'exemple des
puits de carbone invoqués par le
gouvernement comme solution miracle vous
dites au contraire qu'ils ont potentiel
défaillant du fait de l'intensification
des sécheresses phénomène déjà commencé
et voué à s'accentuer dès lors les
effets d'annonce comme un milliard
d'arbres plantés par les écoliers sont
anachroniques sans aller jusqu'à parler
de démagogie car actuellement les puits
de carbone absorbent 4% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et ce malgré une
couverture forestière d'un tiers du
territoire national planter des arbres
n'est donc pas la solution mais un
pansement il faut un plan national de
sobriété en même temps aucune
bifurcation structurelle n'est engagée
les transports restent centrés sur la
bagnole et sont développement 250 000
voitures électriques annuelles annoncées
par Emmanuel Macron et de nouvelles
autoroutes comme la 69 entre Toulouse et
cast mais où sont les transports en
commun et le rail autrefois Florent
français et que dire des millions de
poids lourds à 97% au gasoil en retard
sur la stratégie nationale bas carbone
rien ils ne sont pas évincés des routes
comme notamment à cause de l'abandon du
fret ferroviaire français
pour terminer donc en tant que Haut
Conseil pour le climat comment expliquer
que parmi toutes vos recommandations les
seules retenues le soi grâce à une
opportunité industrielle ou économique à
croire donc les coûts sociaux et de
biodiversité n'entre pas dans l'équation
je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe les républicains la
parole est à
Antoine vers Morel marquez merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente chers collègues tout d'abord
notre groupe vous remercie de votre
présence cet après-midi afin de nous
éclairer sur vos constats et également
vous recommandations concernant la
transition écologique en juin dernier le
Haut Conseil pour le climat a publié son
cinquième rapport annuel qui dénonce le
rythme des réductions deux fois trop
lents des émissions de carbone de la
France au regard de ces engagements pris
dans le cadre de l'accord de Paris alors
que le gouvernement se satisfait d'un
léger mieux par rapport à la période
2015-2018 pour laquelle notre pays a été
condamné pour une action climatique
votre rapport confirme que la baisse de
2,7% mesurait en 2022 et d'abord lié aux
effets conjoncturels de l'hiver doux et
de l'inflation et je vous cite sans que
cela ne permette de conclure que des
politiques structurelles suffisantes ont
été enclenchés à l'issue de la mission
flash sur le respect des engagements
climatiques de la France conduite avec
ma collègue Laurence et del Grière nous
estimons que l'horizon loint les
objectifs de décarbonation ne
favorisaient pas l'action et qu'une loi
de planification écologique assise sur
un pouvoir de contrôle renforcé du
Parlement et de nouveaux moyens accordés
au conseil pour le climat serait
nécessaire à ce titre quels ont été pour
vous les suites de notre mission flash
et notamment en matière de ressources
humaines à ce sujet quel risque
voyez-vous pour la transition écologique
à ce que la loi de programmation
énergique climat ne soit pas comme prévu
voté par le Parlement la planification
écologique des voyait la semaine
dernière par le président Emmanuel
Macron est décliné dans le projet de loi
de finances 2024 est-elle à la hauteur
des enjeux enclenchera-t-elle la
dynamique espérée alors qu'elle ne fait
aucune action de pluriannuel ce qui
manque à notre avis dans ce plan c'est
une politique plus enthousiasmante
d'incitation au changement qui ne
consiste pas à culpabiliser nos
concitoyens mais à leur proposer des
solutions attractives cette écologie
plus humaine et moins punitive passera
enfin par des changements de mode de vie
et de production soumis au débat et
acceptée par les Français enfin notre
groupe s'interroge sur l'importance
donnée à l'atténuation mais aussi à
l'adaptation dans les débats à venir
avez-vous prévu d'inclure ce sujet dans
vos prochains travaux de manière plus
intensive je vous remercie merci pour le
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant la
parole est à uber hot
[Musique]
parmi les premières causes de cette
disparition accélérée du vivant à
l'échelle mondiale un rapport de l'IPBES
paru en 2019 estime que cette 1 million
d'espèces qui sont menacées d'extinction
pour les prochaines décennies du jamais
vu dans l'histoire de l'humanité la
France qui abrite environ 10% de la
biodiversité mondiale et parmi les
premiers pays pour le plus grand nombre
d'espèces en danger les causes de
l'effondrement du vivant sont connus
artificialisation agriculture
exploitation forestière et pollution
figure parmi elles en mélangeant nos
espaces vierges en modifiant nos
pratiques agricoles en réduisant
drastiquement la pollution et en
diversifiant nos productions même en
forêt nous recréerons un paysage à face
multiple un paysage qui fonctionne comme
un écosystème dans nos projets pour la
transition ces évolutions et ses
révolutions doivent absolument devenir
nos priorités nationales ne croyez-vous
pas que c'est en unissant le combat
climatique et le combat pour le vivant
que nous choisirons ces priorités
absolues qui nous feront sortir par le
haut en défendant finalement autant les
conditions pour la vie que la vie
elle-même
merci pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté la parole est à Gérard le seul
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente cher membre du Haut Conseil
pour le climat cher collègue la France
n'est manifestement pas prête à faire
face aux effets du changement climatique
c'est ce que vous mettez dans votre
rapport et en tant que député des
boucles de scène cette citation de votre
rapport résonne terriblement tant je
mesure le risque d'une
élévation du niveau de la mer et donc du
fleuve sur nos communes et vergers de la
vallée de la Seine
les incidences des modifications
climatiques sont énormes reculent du
trait de côte modification des cultures
intermittences de la ressource en eau
c'est périls sont nombreux et nous
aimerions connaître vos recommandations
sur des solutions concrètes de lutte et
d'adaptation à mettre en œuvre dans
votre rapport vous faites aussi la
démonstration que des mesures prises par
le gouvernement vont dans le bon sens
mais ne sont pas suffisantes et pas
assez massives pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
respecter nos engagements internationaux
et nos engagements vis-à-vis de la
population française pour passer à
l'échelle et comme nous le proposons
avec le groupe socialiste dans les
différents débats parlementaires il
apparaît nécessaire et urgent de mettre
des moyens forts notamment sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple le plan
pompe à chaleur annonçait avec
grandiloquence par le président n'est
une nouvelle fois de notre point de vue
pas à la hauteur des enjeux le sujet de
la rénovation énergétique on le sait
c'est la rénovation globale qui seul
permettra une forte réduction des
consommations et des émissions votre
rapport nous invite aussi à une
réflexion sur notre empreinte carbone
globale qui regroupe les émissions
nationales et celles qui s'associent aux
produits que nous importons alors selon
vos chiffres l'empreinte carbone des
importations est une fois et demie plus
importante que les émissions produites
sur le sol national il n'est donc pas
acceptable de déléguer finalement les
émissions polluantes à l'étranger au
mépris de nos règles sociales et
environnementale nos exigences sur la
production nationale doivent être les
mêmes pour les produits que nous
importons que pour celles ceux que nous
produisons ainsi nous aimerions obtenir
votre expertise sur l'effet de
l'application de nos normes
environnementales sur des produits que
nous apportons je vous remercie merci
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté la
parole est à Henri alfonsari merci
monsieur le Président bon je pourrais
faire aussi la lecture de toutes les
catastrophes mais je vous l'avais déjà
très bien fait donc je ne le ferai pas
par contre je vous poserai une question
par exemple sur le stradette à la
question est-ce que c'est bien la bonne
échelle est-ce que ce sera d'être
quelque part n'est pas trop petit pour
avoir une vraie politique globale et
trop grand pour descendre dans le niveau
de finesse que nous avons besoin je
m'explique par exemple sur une question
que j'ai eu tout récemment on a
reconstruit la charpente de Notre-Dame
on la reconstruit en partie avec du bois
vert comme ça se faisait il y a
plusieurs siècles enfin au moment où ça
a été fait et c'est bien plus efficace
et on parle de bois qui vont avoir entre
50 et 80 ans sur le terrain l'ensemble
des propriétaires forestiers savent
qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir penser
effectivement à ne plus récolter un
arbre à 120 ans 150 ans mais vrai que tu
es à 50 80 ans or
il n'y a pas de rapprochement entre les
deux visiblement on arrive à faire ce
constat dans un secteur le faire dans un
autre or personne n'arrive à
restructurer une filière avec ses
informations là autre question qui me
pose c'est la question toutes les villes
pompes leur eau dans le phénomania
toutes ces taux est rejeté à la mer or
il suffirait de 30% ses taux pour faire
les usages agricoles et par ailleurs ça
permettrait dans le cycle de l'eau de
bien mieux gérer la baisse des
températures au sol une meilleure
biodiversité et autres je n'ai pas
l'impression que le stradette puisse
répondre à ce genre de problématique
d'une manière générale je vais vous
poser deux questions votre apport dit
que l'adaptation doit devenir préventive
et transformatrice en anticipant bien en
amont les changements futurs qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de l'application
actuelle du principe de précaution par
rapport à cette phrase là est-ce que il
n'y a pas quelque chose d'assez
contradictoire entre figé une approche
à l'instant T alors qu'on doit être dans
une nature prospective et une capacité
d'évolution et la deuxième chose c'est
c'est bien le carbone qui nous occupe il
faut qu'on enlève notamment ce qu'on a
mis dans l'atmosphère je sais que vous
avez travaillé sur ces questions là
madame la Présidente donc comme est-ce
que vous avez pensé d'une manière ou
d'une autre à le monétiser
la parole est à Cyrielle châtelain merci
monsieur le Président et merci madame la
Présidente d'être venue nous présenter
les conclusions de votre travail qui est
extrêmement riche extrêmement solide et
qui je crois doit tous nous inspirer je
voudrais commencer par vous peut-être
vous présenter des excuses que vous ayez
dès la deuxième intervention dans cette
assemblée de la part du rassemblement
national des propos climato-sceptiques
oui la France représente 1% des
émissions comme 180 en fait on a 199
pays qui représentent 1% ou moins des
émissions aujourd'hui ce propos là de
minorer notre rôle à qu'un seul objectif
c'est de nous empêcher d'avancer la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut prendre
en compte la responsabilité historique
d'un pays telle que la France dans les
émissions cumulées de gaz à effet de
serre et je pense que c'était essentiel
je retiens de votre intervention et du
travail qui a été fait madame la
Présidente effectivement l'aspect
conjoncturel notamment des baisses de
2022 qui doit nous alerter sur la
nécessité de prendre des mesures fortes
et structurelles dès maintenant la
deuxième chose je retiens l'opportunité
que peut représenter la lpk et j'espère
qu'on aura l'occasion d'avoir un débat
parlementaire rapidement sur sur cette
loi que je pense nous attendons tous et
qui oui peut être une véritable
opportunité enfin je retiens aussi
l'importance de préserver les puits
carbone et donc important d'arrêter un
certain nombre de projets aujourd'hui
climaticides notamment de projets
autoroutiers pour les préserver enfin
j'aurais deux questions vous parlez d'un
manque d'une politique économique
permettant d'atteindre les objectifs
est-ce que vous pourriez développer un
peu la politique économique qui vous
semblerait pertinente notamment il me
semble qu'on a une question sur la
dépendance aux énergies fossiles on a un
certain nombre de très grandes
entreprises aujourd'hui qui notamment
totale continue à développer des projets
que ça soit en Ouganda ou au Suriname
qui remettent en cause en fait toute
l'action qu'on est en train de faire
donc à la fois quelle politique
économique d'incitation quelle politique
par rapport dans son grandes entreprises
notamment par rapport à l'appel des
scientifiques sur la non prolifération
de vos projets fossiles et le deuxième
la deuxième question c'est sur les
ménage modestes vous avez parlé de
l'impact des politiques
environnementales que peut avoir sur eux
est-ce que moi il me semble que
notamment dans les personnes qui
subissent les impacts du dérecquement de
climatique on a de nombreux ménages
modestes et ce que vous dire sur des
étudier le profil notamment des
personnes qui subissent ces impacts du
réchauffement je vous remercie merci
pour la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
la parole est à Hubert vulfran
[Musique]
quelques années ce qui est largement
insuffisant en matière de décarbonation
vous notez une trajectoire similaire
insatisfaisante pour les véhicules
utilitaires légers
donc en matière de frais de marchandise
la route domine toujours très largement
et ne remplit pas ses objectifs de
décarbonation
le fait de ferroviaire dont l'enjeu de
développement est majeur est guidé comme
vous le rappelez par la stratégie
nationale dont vous indiquez brièvement
je cite qu'elle comporte peu de mesure
incitatives ou réglementaires favorisant
notre activité du train et le report
modal par ailleurs une période
relativement incertaine s'ouvre
pour le fret ferroviaire alors je
voudrais simplement dans ce débat
récurrent que vous reveniez sur un
certain nombre de peut-être préciser les
préconisations qui qui serait selon vous
nécessaire dans ces stratégies aux fins
d'assurer un report modal au bon rythme
merci
merci chers collègues madame la
Présidente je vous laisse le soin de
répondre à nos orateurs de groupe en
sachant que nous avons d'ores et déjà
une petite dizaine de questions d'une
minute
merci beaucoup pour ces questions très
très riches et aussi pour avoir pris la
peine de consulter notre rapport déjà si
je les prends en ordre et ensuite je
vous demande de compléter la sur les
éléments
autres vous avez donné l'exemple madame
milfar meunier du zan et des réticences
en fait de l'engagement des citoyens au
travers la France et des réticences
qu'on peut avoir ce qui amène à ralentir
les politiques publiques donc
malheureusement c'est une réalité que
l'on doit aller plus vite au niveau de
l'implémentation de l'accélération des
mesures et ça veut dire que on touche en
fait à la vie quotidienne de chacun un
des éléments vraiment crucial que nous
avons essayé de faire ressortir dans
notre rapport c'est justement la
disponibilité des options à un coût
abordable accessibilité des différentes
options et c'est bien là où on peut
avoir des avancées importantes c'est à
dire de regarder la société bas carbone
de demain qui est celle qui est en route
elle est en route en France elle est en
route en Europe il est en route aux
États-Unis elle est en route en Chine
elle est en route de par le monde donc
c'est la société globale que nous aurons
et c'est de regarder qui comment est-ce
qu'on peut rendre cette société
accessible à tout un chacun si on prend
l'exemple des transports bien sûr il y a
le transport collectif là où il existe
ou c'est possible et où on peut le
développer de manière pratique et
abordable mais bien sûr il y a aussi le
le l'électrification du parc automobile
on a noté dans notre rapport une
tendance à ce niveau c'est-à-dire que
les producteurs produisent des voitures
qui sont de plus en plus grosses de plus
en plus lourdes et du coup moins de
moins en moins abordable et c'est un
exemple typique de la transition bas
carbone où on veut faire une transition
vers l'électrique et que on l'a fait de
manière à ce que elle soit pas
accessible à l'ensemble de la population
et donc là on a eu une recommandation
très forte et qui a été entendue jusqu'à
un certain point c'est-à-dire d'essayer
de influencer déjà l'accessibilité la
production du passage à l'électrique
vers des voitures qui sont beaucoup plus
accessibles mais aussi de regarder le
marché de second main dans ce cas
spécifique et bien sûr en parallèle de
rendre plus accessible le transport
actif et le transport collectif on voit
bien vous avez mentionné Lausanne mais
il y a aussi le problème se retrouve au
niveau des ETFE au niveau justement
une chaudière à gaz et donc on doit
vraiment le gouvernement doit vraiment
et l'ensemble du secteur public regardez
comment est-ce qu'on a sur une
transition juste dans l'ensemble et une
transition juste ce n'est pas une
transition que simplement
articuler au niveau du cou mais au
niveau de l'accessibilité pour
l'ensemble de la population c'est aussi
une transition qui doit avoir une
trajectoire très visible pour l'ensemble
des acteurs une trajectoire pour les
producteurs une trajectoire pour les
ménages une trajectoire pour l'industrie
et là vous ne m'avez demandé monsieur le
Président de commenter sur les annonces
qui ont été fait justement depuis la
publication de notre rapport et on voit
que la plupart de ces annonces elles
vont dans le bon sens mais on voit pas
encore la trajectoire jusqu'à la
neutralité carbone ou au moins jusqu'à
l'horizon 2030 se dessiner donc c'est là
vraiment où on a un travail collectif à
faire mené par le gouvernement avec la à
l'appui
la publication et le travail fait du
SGPA derrière mais pour dessiner cette
trajectoire de manière la plus
opérationnelle possible d'identifier
d'où viendra le financement quelle est
la part publique quelle est la part
publique privée et comment est-ce qu'on
articule tout ça donc le langagement des
collectivités l'engagement des régions
et fondamentales parce que les régions
auront des circonstances spécifiques et
que c'est vraiment important de voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut articuler les
politiques nationales au niveau régional
et ça ça ne peut se faire que avec un
engagement très important et donc les
coffres régionales s'inscrivent dans
cette voie là qu'elle pourra être le
rôle du Haut Conseil pour le climat il y
a des hauts conseils régionaux qui sont
en train d'émerger dans les diverses
régions je les encourage parce que ça
amène justement un regard différent sur
cet articulation régionale nationale et
nous au conseil pour le climat on a on a
a selon la loi climat résilience on doit
rendre un rapport sur les régions qui
sera viendra probablement 2025 et c'est
à ce moment là où on pourra se pencher
plus en détail sur le rôle des régions
le en ce qui concerne les émissions la
contribution de la France aux émissions
mondiales donc monsieur Morin donc vous
avez parlé bien sûr bien sûr moins de 1%
pour la France on le sait tous donc la
France elle a un rôle à jouer comme tous
les autres pays les émissions par
personne sont importantes mais plus
important encore vous avez parlé de la
France comme étant les bons élèves mais
elle est quand même en train de se faire
rattraper quelque part par d'autres pays
c'est-à-dire que la France elle est
pratiquement sortie du charbon pas
encore et c'est dommage mais ces
émissions nationales diminuent jusqu'à
très récemment de environ 2% par an on a
vu des années avec un peu plus de
virgule 7 mais c'est pas encore la
tendance bien ancrée il y a plusieurs
pays qui sont sortis complètement du
charbon il y a plusieurs pays qui
baissent leurs émissions à des rythmes
de 3 à 4% par année et donc et donc la
France n'est plus du tout toute seule il
y a tous les pays européens qui avancent
au même rythme la France elle risque
d'être en retard si justement elle prend
pas le tournant d'accélérer le plus vite
possible sa tendance et son
industrialisation ou peu importe les
choix politiques qui sont faits derrière
mais qui soit des choix bas carbone
si on veut reculer sur certaines
politiques climatiques il faut que les
parties soient capables de dire comment
est-ce qu'elles vont atteindre les
objectifs qui sont franchement très
importants parce que comme vous le savez
comme vous l'avez vu on l'a vu cet été
on l'a vu l'année dernière la France
elle est particulièrement exposée au
changement climatique plus que les
autres pays et que on va souffrir en
France si on n'est pas capable de
d'entraîner au niveau mondial la baisse
en émission nécessaire pour stabiliser
le climat
51% des importations merci de nous le
rappeler vous avez complètement raison
que l'emprunt carbone de la France est
les plus élevés une fois une demi plus
élevée que les émissions nationales et
donc il faut aussi que la France elle
s'occupe elle se préoccupe de des
émissions associées à ces importations
nous avons publié un rapport sur
justement ces émissions en 2019 qui est
encore d'actualité et qui dit que
au moins trois quarts des décisions
reliées aux importations sont faites par
des acteurs français donc ce sont soit
les ménages avec avec leur pouvoir
d'achat avec ce qu'ils achètent soit les
entreprises avec la source et l'origine
de leurs produits qui sont parfois
assemblées en France donc on doit bien
prendre en compte ces flux ces flux
d'émissions nous avons recommandé nous
de d'inscrire les émissions de
l'empreinte carbone dans les budgets
carbone du de la France le gouvernement
s'est engagée dans la loi de 2019 à
donner un seuil à ne pas dépasser pour
ses émissions on a proposé des chiffres
et une trajectoire je pense que c'est ça
qu'il faut faire il faut appuyer les
ménages et les organismes et les
entreprises pour pour qu'il puisse
engager des choix bas carbone ça sera
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit ça
va augmenter justement la compétitivité
de la France mais plus encore ça va
engager inciter les pays qui importent
en France à réduire leurs émissions
c'est aussi la direction du sébum qui
est le ministre le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières de
l'Europe
donc ces émissions importées il ne faut
pas les négliger maintenant si on veut
une réindustrialisation c'est un choix
politique du gouvernement il faut
cependant qu'elle soit bas carbone
donc voilà
pour le
en ce qui concerne les plus de carbone
Marion je vais te demander dans une
minute de prendre la parole
vous avez parlé donc Sylvain carrière
maintenant je sais plus où vous êtes ah
voilà merci donc effectivement le plan
national de sobriété que vous allez
mentionné pour pour
atteindre les objectifs de 2030 il faut
vraiment aller très vite et donc la
sobriété doit vraiment être au centre de
ces politiques c'est absolument
fondamental maintenant la sobriété c'est
pas de tout faire comme on fait dans
l'actuel et en bout de course dire on
vous présente toutes ces offres
alléchantes mais surtout ni touchez pas
parce que ça émet du carbone il faut
vraiment
focaliser la sobriété surtout l'offre
qui est au consommateur et donc la
production et donc et donc et donc toute
la chaîne de tout l'ensemble de
l'économie et je reviens à mon exemple
de cette voiture donc j'ai parlé des
voitures électriques qui doivent être
petites les voitures aussi thermique ont
une tendance surtout les voitures
thermiques ont une tendance à devenir de
plus en plus grosse c'est un exemple
d'une offre qui n'est plus acceptable
parce que c'est une offre qui est de
plus en plus carbonée alors que on
devrait plutôt avoir une offre inverse
qui est une offre qui est de plus en
plus sobre pour le consommateur et
justement la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments s'inscrit dans cette offre
sobre c'est à dire que en accompagnement
du remplacement des chaudières à gaz
vers des pompes à chaleur on doit aussi
isoler les bâtiments pour réduire les
demandes énergétiques ce qui va aussi
faciliter du coup les besoins de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et du système électrique qui va avec
pour continuer donc sur les suites de
votre mission flash et si le plan de le
PLF du coup est à la hauteur des
ambitions donc là on a vu quand même une
augmentation substantielle du coup du
budget bas carbone de 7 milliards plus 3
milliards engagés de permission de
dépenses la teinte pour la part publique
est plutôt vers les 30 milliards en 2030
donc si est-ce que ça suffit dépend de
la trajectoire qu'il y aura derrière
est-ce que justement le ministère des
Finances est effectivement en train de
réfléchir à tracer cette trajectoire
assortir les financements aux énergies
fossiles où les subventions actuelles à
les sortir selon une trajectoire très
très visible pour que les différents
acteurs puissent s'ajuster à l'heure
actuelle on n'a pas l'information parce
que le PLF concerne simplement de 1024
donc vous avez complètement raison que
l'on doit avoir une trajectoire non
seulement qui est plus réelle mais qui
apporte déjà une visibilité jusqu'à la
teinte de la neutralité carbone en 2050
donc au même titre pratiquement que
l'éducation est que la santé la
transition énergétique maintenant elle
doit être au cœur de des préoccupations
de l'ensemble des des décideurs
politiques et de l'ensemble de la
population
sur les espèces et la biodiversité je
vais laisser ma collègue Marion Guillou
répondre si on continue sur le les
rénovations énergétiques du bâtiment je
pense que j'ai répondu déjà au niveau
justement le fait que les pompes à
chaleur oui c'est un élément il faut
aussi regarder dans l'ensemble et qu'on
pourra pas atteindre la neutralité
carbone en considérant les demandes
énergétiques actuelles dans le bâtiment
il faut vraiment réduire la demande
énergétique je veux cependant soulever
le profiter de la question pour soulever
le fait que la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments c'est le secteur qui coûte
le plus cher en termes de transition bas
carbone et c'est vraiment pour ce
secteur où on doit avoir une visibilité
d'ensemble à très très long terme pour
justement que l'on puisse
engagé les développements de toute la
filière et Marion je vais te demander de
parler aussi des filières dans ta
réponse s'il te plaît
l'emprunt carbone on a déjà couvert au
niveau des stadettes comme je vous
l'avais dit malheureusement on n'a pas
travaillé sur les aspects régionaux
cette année par contre par le passé on a
noté que il y avait un déphasage on voit
bien là du coup il y a déjà un déphasage
entre les objectifs qui ont été votés au
niveau européen en juillet 2021 et les
objectifs qui sont maintenant déclinés
pour 2032 ans plus tard dans les pays et
il y a même des phasage du coup qui se
trouve à
qui se trouve à être au niveau régional
et justement tous ces instruments de
politique publique doivent être mieux
articulées et entre eux et j'espère que
ça sera aussi un des éléments de travail
qui pourront être intégrés au sein du
lgpa je le pense
le principe de précaution est monétisé
le carbone effectivement donc on a toute
une réflexion à faire au niveau des plus
de carbone maintenant attention parce
que mes plus de carbone à moi en tant
que scientifique ce sont des plus
naturels et ça compte pas quand on parle
de neutralité carbone on parle vraiment
du carbone qu'on a travaillé pour lequel
on a travaillé on parle de de renforcer
le stock de carbone dans les sols
agricoles et on parle de planter des
armes dans les forêts et éventuellement
les plus de carbone technologiques où on
peut extraire le carbone de l'atmosphère
effectivement le manque de marché par
rapport à à ses plus de carbone nous
aide pas que il y a une réflexion à
faire possiblement au niveau du système
d'échange de quota européen qu'il y a
déjà des il y a déjà des éléments en
route mais là du coup on n'a pas creusé
donc je peux pas vous amener plus
d'éléments mais j'en profite juste pour
dire que effectivement
c'est un aspect à soulever
finalement encore deux trois questions
que auxquelles j'ai pas répondu je pense
que on a parlé de politique économique
suffisamment j'en profite peut-être pour
dire que sur la lpk et le débat
parlementaire c'est important que les
objectifs climatiques soient des
objectifs qui est un poids juridique
important plus le poids juridique est
important plus on a des chances qui
seront effectivement
atteints et donc effectivement d'avoir
au moins une loi qui encre dans la loi
les objectifs climatiques nous avons
fait un certain nombre de
recommandations par rapport à ce qui
pourrait être inscrit dans la loi donc
l'objectif non seulement l'objectif de
neutralité carbone togaz mais l'objectif
CO2 seulement ce qui nous permet
d'articuler et l'objectif émissions brut
ce qui nous permet d'articuler les
objectifs en termes de plus de carbone
et d'émissions brutes mais aussi
l'objectif de méthane parce que la
France a signé la déclaration
internationale le globulesmaten pledge
mais elle n'a pas encore annoncé comment
elle allait contribuer à cet objectif
est-ce qu'il s'agit de 30% de
décroissance de méthane en France ou
autre et ça du coup ça doit être
articulé et annoncer et à notre avis
inscrit dans la loi
effectivement en fait toute la France
subit les impacts du changement
climatique bien sûr les impacts sont
toujours plus visibles pour les ménages
modestes et c'est très très important de
pouvoir dans le contexte d'une
transition juste de pouvoir protéger les
ménages à la fois des impacts
climatiques mais aussi des actions
qu'ils devront mettre en route pour
pouvoir faire leur contribution
[Musique]
je vous en prie je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président donc j'ai
retenu cinq ou six questions que je vais
essayer de traiter peut-être pas aussi
rapidement que que Corinne qui a
magnifiquement enchaîné les questions
alors sur le lien biodiversité qui m'a
oui il y a un lien évident d'abord la
diversification biologique ça donne une
résilience au changement climatique
c'est le fait de ne pas avoir des
populations totalement homogènes ça vous
rend plus résilient ça garde ça permet
de garder une capacité d'adaptation
c'est à dire que vous voyez dans les par
exemple dans les végétaux si vous n'avez
pas de conservatoire de végétaux vous
n'aurez pas forcément les plantes
adaptées au climat de demain donc il est
extrêmement important de garder une
diversité non seulement d'espèces et
c'est ce à quoi vous faisiez allusion
mais aussi une diversité à l'intérieur
des espèces pour avoir je sais pas il
faut je crois qu'on a 30000 blés dans
les conservatoires de l'inrae et il y en
a certains qui résistent au froid
d'autres qui résistent au chaud d'autres
qui aimeront et c'est vraiment une
assurance vie biologique pour pour
l'avenir en fait de garder cette
diversité et je vais vous donner un
autre exemple je sais pas si ça va vous
faire sourire ou pas quand on parle de
l'élevage on doit effectivement réduire
de l'empreinte carbone et méthane
surtout de l'élevage et il y a une des
solutions qui est proposée qui est
d'avancer l'âge du premier village parce
qu'actuellement on garde des génies
jusqu'à 24 mois et jusque enfin si vous
voulez de manière
inutile au sens biologique et mission du
terme certaines races comme des races
Angus ou des rats airford savent veiller
avant les 24 mois donc de faire des
croisements une diversité génétique ça
vous permettra d'avancer l'âge des
villages et ça peut jouer jusqu'à 17%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
quand vous supprimez plusieurs mois de
présence d'animaux donc oui la
biodiversité du climat sont totalement
liées je ne sais pas si j'avais besoin
d'aller jusque à l'âge des villages mais
vous voyez bien que il y a une
effectivement beaucoup de liens alors
pourquoi vous disiez de fait écologie
punitive pourquoi les ces mesures
injustes moi je dirais plus que si on ne
fait rien c'est totalement injuste vous
savez que ce sont les populations
pauvres qui vont souffrir le plus du
changement climatique au niveau mondial
bien sûr mais aussi au niveau national
ce sont ceux qui ont des passoires
thermiques qui vont souffrir du froid ou
du chaud donc au contraire avoir une
politique climatique c'est protéger les
populations alors il faut évidemment
faire attention à ce que les mesures
comprennent soit socialement justes
c'est verrier au moment où on prend des
mesures sur le
par exemple les carburants ou autre
qu'il n'y ait pas de répartition ou des
compensations pour les populations qui
qui pâtiraient mais par contre les
politiques climatiques sont politiques
de protection des populations pauvres
le troisième élément on parlait de
d'empreinte oui effectivement
l'empreinte c'est donc ce qu'on produit
les gaz les émissions liées à ce qu'on
produit sur le territoire plus les
émissions liées à ce qui est important
et l'empreinte alimentaire je vous donne
cet exemple elle est presque deux fois
plus que l'empreinte de l'agriculture et
de fait 45% de l'empreinte alimentaire
est liée aux importations ça a des
implications c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
qu'on dise à la Commission européenne
que lorsqu'on négocie des traités
commerciaux on doit veiller à aux
conditions qui sont fixées dans les
traités commerciaux par rapport aux
produits importés qui pourraient venir
remplacer les produits nationaux ce
serait absurde d'une certaine manière
d'empirer notre empreinte gaz à effet de
serre en ne veillant pas aux conditions
d'importation
le quatrième point sur les puits carbone
effectivement c'est un phénomène assez
récent mais extrêmement rapide la
mortalité des arbres du fait notamment
des successions d'épisodes de sécheresse
des attaques de scoli ou de parasites
des frênes des châtaigniers des pins
enfin je suppose que vous en avez vu
partout dans vos régions on fait on
causé une augmentation de 54% de la
mortalité des arbres en 9 ans je sais
pas si vous voyez le choc biologique que
ça représenté pour nos forêts la France
et traditionnellement un pays qui a de
nombreuses forêts la superficie en forêt
pas toujours de qualité parfois sont
désagrus simplement des terrains
agricoles de la déprise agricole et des
agrux forestiers mais on a une surface
forestière significative et très
récemment donc du fait des conditions
climatiques on a constaté une baisse
significative des puits de carbone leur
baisse des puits de carbone forestiers
et baisse des puits de carbone dans les
sols
vous savez que dans les sols il y a
trois fois plus de stockage de carbone
que dans l'atmosphère enfin je sais pas
si vous le saviez mais en tous les cas
je vous le dis le sol dans la couche de
0 à 2 mètres stocke trois fois plus de
carbone que l'atmosphère
donc oui donc il est extrêmement
important de de faire en sorte que c'est
puis de carbone soit entretenu mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire
effectivement replanter des forêts et là
il faut choisir les espèces ça n'est pas
du tout inutile de replanter un
milliards d'arbres par contre il faut
replanter des espèces qui seront
adaptées aux conditions futures il faut
de la même manière faire en sorte que
les stockages de carbone dans les dans
les seuls augmentent et là ça suppose à
la fois des pratiques agricoles
favorisant le stockage de carbone dans
les sols et sans doute d'encourager les
agriculteurs pour qu'ils deviennent ce
qu'on appelle des carboniculteurs mais
aussi de lutter contre
l'artificialisation des sols parce que
un parking qui est recouvert de macadam
c'est un sol qui ne respire plus et
c'est un sol qui est donc c'est mauvais
pour la vie dans le sol donc mauvais
pour le stockage de carbone dans le sol
donc là ce sont des mesures assez
simples pour ceux qui ont une influence
locale sont des mesures réceptions
d'éviter l'imperméabilisation des sols
alors évidemment miroir artificiel
artivation net ça et l'effet est plus
radical puisque ça suppose de veiller à
ce qu'on n'est pas trop de disparition
de surface mais c'est une mesure
indispensable pour la vie dans les sols
et donc pour le stockage de carbone dans
les sols et enfin j'insiste sur le fait
qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir une
programmation pluriannuelle en reprenant
ce que Corinne disait parce que quand on
parle forêt quand on parle stockage de
carbone dans les sols quand on parle
changement de pratique agricoles on
parle de changement de long terme et
pour que les acteurs acceptent des
changements de long terme il faut une
visibilité et d'où l'importance
effectivement au-delà des sommes
importantes qui ont été dégagées par le
gouvernement d'avoir une visibilité plus
réelle des actions peut-être faut-il
ajouter que le bureau que le budget du
Haut Conseil Paul climat nécessite aussi
une mesure de je crois 250 kg euros pour
ceux qui auront envie de faire des
amendements pour arriver à faire tourner
le nombre de rapports qu'on a à faire
merci de votre attention
merci pour vos propos et les réponses
très complètes apportées aux orateurs
des groupes nous en venons aux questions
d'une minute avec la question de
Laurence et del gruyère
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente en juin le Haut Conseil pour
le climat rendu son rapport annuel 2023
il constate une baisse des émissions de
CO2 dans notre pays mais cette baisse
est insuffisante il faut amplifier nos
efforts c'est pourquoi la planification
écologique présentée lundi dernier par
le Président de la République prend tout
son sens cependant comme j'ai pu le
souligner dans un récent courrier
adressé au Ministre Christophe Béchu
chacun doit prendre sa part dans ce
tournant y compris nos territoires
ruraux or je constate que le mot
ruralité n'apparaît pas une seule fois
dans les 200 pages de votre rapport pas
une seule celui de Dakar d'agriculture
apparaît lui 57 fois de là imaginé que
le Haut Conseil pour les climats résume
la ruralité à l'agriculture je ne me le
permettrai pas parce que la ruralité
c'est bien plus que cela alors madame la
Présidente pouvez-vous nous préciser
quels sont les recommandations du Haut
Conseil pour le climat pour que la
transition écologique soit à la hauteur
des enjeux mais surtout juste et adapté
pour notre ruralité je vous remercie
la parole est à Laurence pardon à
Charlotte Gauthier
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je tiens à souligner la
qualité du rapport intitulé à telle
urgence engager les moyens vous avez
réalisé une présentation pertinente de
ce rapport je souhaiterais insister sur
un point l'adaptation au réchauffement
climatique plus 2 degrés à l'horizon
2030 le constat nécessite une politique
ambitieuse en matière d'adaptation que
penser que proposez-vous concrètement
pour répondre à cet enjeu je vous
remercie
très bonne question merci chers
collègues la parole est à Daniel
brulbois
pardon elle est sortie mais on lui a la
parole la parole est à Damien Adam
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
mesdames et messieurs pour votre
présence cet après-midi une de vos
recommandations et je le cite compléter
et publié l'ensemble des feuilles de
roue de décarbonation des secteurs et
filières les articuler entre elles et
ont assuré le niveau en cohérence avec
les objectifs climatiques de court terme
et la teinte de la neutralité carbone en
2050 ce qui m'amène à ma question par
rapport à au plan annoncé par le sgpe
sur la planification et les 50 de
leviers qu'ils ont identifiés pour
atteindre nos objectifs de 2030 est-ce
que vous avez prévu dans un prochain
rapport d'analyser très finement ces 50
de leviers identifiés par le fgpe pour
en voir si ça permet d'atteindre les
objectifs et si ça vous paraît réaliste
et s'il faut ajuster les choses par
rapport à ça ça nous a ça nous guiderait
nous parlementaire de manière très
précise pour nous permettre de savoir si
on est dans le plan de marche il faut
améliorer les choses ou pas je vous
remercie
merci la parole est manuelle Maquet
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente le Haut Conseil pour le
climat a été créé par Emmanuel Macron en
2018 ironiquement chaque fois que la
presse relay vos rapports depuis c'est
pour dire que vous dénoncez
l'inefficacité de sa politique
climatique il y a beaucoup à dire sur
l'aveuglement du gouvernement notamment
en matière d'énergie nucléaire mais
est-ce bien un rôle du Conseil d'experts
de ce comporter comme un contre-pouvoir
politique
usant des médias pour faire de la
communication auprès du grand public
dans le contexte de désaffection
croissante de nos concitoyens vers leurs
institutions n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment de participer à la défiance
ambiante en prenant systématiquement
partie contre une action publique que
vous êtes censée éclairer je rappelle
que le propre du pouvoir politique c'est
d'arbitrer et de concilier des intérêts
parfois contradictoires à votre avis la
multiplication des rapports à l'armistes
et culpabilisant a-t-elle démontré son
efficacité au service de la cause
climatique merci
merci la parole est à Daniel brulbois
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente les techniques de captage et
de stockage du carbone
sont apparaissent comme une solution
qu'elle soit naturelle ou qu'elle soit
industrielle
donc ça lève quand même un espoir
important
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire si vous
êtes d'accord avec l'Agence
internationale internationale de
l'énergie ou la Commission européenne
qui les considère comme une solution
qu'il faut absolument encourager et que
ça peut être un espoir pour l'humanité
merci la parole est à Madame Christelle
PETEX levée
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues madame la Présidente dans
votre dernier rapport vous réitérez la
recommandation de sortir du charbon dès
2023 promesse maintes fois à journée par
Emmanuel Macron et encore une fois
exprimée la semaine dernière avec une
mise en application seulement pour 2027
partagez-vous le constat que le
nucléaire est un atout indispensable
pour garantir notre approvisionnement en
électricité sans dépendre des énergies
fossiles nous nous étonnons en effet que
la relance du nucléaire ne figure à
aucun moment parmi vos recommandations
alors que l'idée fait de plus en plus
consensus dans l'opinion et commence
même à faire son chemin chez certains
exposants en revanche vous prenez sans
réserve l'accélération du déploiement
des énergies renouvelables quelle
estimation le Haut Conseil pour le
climat fait-il des émissions de carbone
nécessaires au fonctionnement de ces
procédés et quelle énergie de
substitution préconisez-vous pour
pallier l'intermittence du solaire ou de
l'éolien quel jugement portez-vous sur
la stratégie française de création de
terminaux métallier accueillant du GN
afin de le substituer au gaz russe le
déploiement d'une filière française de
biogaz n'aurait-il pas été plus
pertinent je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Jean-Pierre tête
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente cette semaine se tient le
Sommet de l'élevage à Cournon-d'Auvergne
l'occasion pour notre groupe de
réaffirmer notre entière confiance à nos
agriculteurs et de rappeler que grâce à
eux l'agriculture française est reconnue
comme le modèle le plus durable au monde
victime d'une concurrence déloyale de
pays étrangers peu vertueux dans leur
pratique et confrontés à des conditions
de travail et de revenus de plus en plus
difficiles nos éleveurs sont aujourd'hui
accusés d'être les premiers responsables
de l'explosion des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre notamment du méthane de
qui se Moquet sur des recommandations
soi-disant scientifiques beaucoup se
sont orientés vers d'autres productions
comme les légumineuses qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à la demande
sociétale ces recommandations abouties à
affaiblir la ferme France au profit
d'importation étrangères est-ce le rôle
d'une instance scientifique comme le
Haut Conseil pour le climat de
s'immiscer dans la vie des gens jusqu'à
leur réclamer un changement d'habitude
alimentaire là où le reste du monde
continue de produire ou de manger de la
viande le climat n'est-il pas le
prétexte pour des climatologues limitant
de condamner définitivement notre
élevage
merci la parole est à Hubert hôte merci
monsieur le Président j'ai bien je vous
ai bien écouté madame tout à l'heure et
je vous rejoins parfaitement dans votre
constat de préciser que le sol est un
considérable
piège à carbone or l'agriculture de ce
point de vue là est potentiellement un
allié considérable on sait aujourd'hui
qu'une proportion significative de nos
terres arables de nos terres cultivées
non plus le caractère vivant qui devrait
être le leur pour jouer à plein leur
rôle de piège à carbone il nous les
intrants qui sont d'ailleurs le résultat
d'une filière pétrolifère quand même
l'intrant de synthèse un ensemble de
pratiques ne sont pas compatibles avec
cette évolution vers un sol vivant un
sol dynamique un sol profond un sol qui
ce qui joue un rôle essentiel si l'on
veut contribuer à cette atténuation
climatique par le piège à carbone que ce
sol présente comme atout majeur
j'aimerais avoir deux renseignements de
votre part avez-vous la proportion de
ces sols sur lesquels on peut engager
une dynamique agricole nouvelle et sur
les pratiques que vous proposez merci
merci la parole est à Gérard le seul
merci Président nous avons à plusieurs
reprises évoquées une question
absolument fondamentale comment
concilier environnement et justice
sociale et à ce titre toutes vos
préconisations seront les bienvenus et
puis en complément des plantes se briété
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de baisse depuis de
carbone vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure à travers les forêts il apparaît
des techniques d'élimination du carbone
de captation de stockage que ce soit le
biochard ou de réutilisation du CO2 à la
sortie de nos usines ou même dans l'air
à ce stade il semble que ces techniques
ne soient pas toutes matures mais en
face de développement et peut-être pour
certaines d'entre elles extrêmement
prometteuses et donc nous souhaiterions
avoir votre avis sur ces techniques qui
est notamment donc sur les plus
prometteuses dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et sur le niveau
d'engagement que devrait prendre la
France pour accompagner ce développement
merci la parole est à 20 cm
merci monsieur le président
ma question est très simple en fait je
voudrais juste savoir comment vous
évaluez les effets compte productif
d'éventuellement d'atteindre de certains
objectifs
je m'explique notamment et vous l'avez
mais dans le mettez dans le rapport la
baisse constatée sera l'agriculture et
surtout lié au fait de la baisse de du
cheptel de bovins notamment le prix des
engrais mais le constat aussi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
l'agriculture est de moins en moins
exportatrice et nous apportons de plus
en plus de denrées c'est-à-dire que nous
nous à travers l'agriculture mais c'est
vrai pour d'autres secteurs où on met
des contraintes fortes par pour répondre
à nos objectifs et notre mission au
niveau français on voit on constate
aussi que du coup comme on importe comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure on peut
importer aussi des produits qui viennent
de l'étranger comment vous évaluez aussi
cet impact cet impact carbone qui est
important puisque du coup c'est plus de
mouvement aussi en termes de transport
de l'étranger vers la France donc est-ce
que vous avez une méthode aujourd'hui
pour vraiment prendre en compte cette
partie là c'est à dire que c'est on
mesure que les gaz effets de 0,2
français sans prendre en compte les
potentialités extérieures c'est
peut-être un petit peu contre-productif
voilà tout simplement ici la parole est
à Sylvie Ferrer
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente chers collègues donc je
voulais faire une petite repas marque
sur les propos de Madame Guillou tout à
l'heure qui a mis au futur en fait
l'impact du dérèglement climatique sur
sur les populations les plus précaires
donc voilà moi je pense que c'est
aujourd'hui
et déjà le l'Impact a déjà commencé
voilà donc là c'était une petite
remarque et
donc madame la Présidente vous avez
abordé déjà la question du poids des
véhicules donc je voulais revenir sur
sur ce sur cette question là puisque
c'est l'objet de ma question et
l'illustrer notamment par par
mon propos donc concernant une blague
assez répandue qui était de déplacer
discrètement la voiture d'un copain et
on l'a porté ailleurs avec quelques bras
c'était assez c'était quelque chose qui
se faisait quoi voilà donc aujourd'hui
totalement impossible de le reproduire
et je suis à peu près sûr que la jeune
génération ne voit pas à quoi je fais
allusion des voitures sont plus lourdes
plus grosses et se gonflement des
machines s'illustre bien au travers de
la prolifération des SUV en 2020 les
ventes de véhicules tout terrain de
loisirs les SUV représenter
39,2% des ventes donc je vais venir à ma
question les voitures électriques sont
en partie nos solutions mais également
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un levier majeur
pour le secteur automobile français
concernant simplement la taille des
véhicules construits merci merci
quand vous allez laisser poser la
question une minute 30 mais c'était pour
rappeler les bons souvenirs de l'époque
est-ce que tous les collègues ont pu
s'exprimer d'autres questions et bien je
vous laisse le soin de répondre et vous
avez vu que votre audition suscite
l'intérêt certain
très très bien merci merci pour cette
deuxième série de questions donc sur la
ruralité donc mais vous avez
complètement raison que c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour un manque d'intérêt que
l'on n'a pas mentionné la ruralité dans
notre rapport cette année c'est
simplement que on n'a pas eu les
ressources pour faire un travail fin qui
dépasse le niveau national donc on a
fait une section régionale dans
certaines nos rapports par le passé mais
cette année on n'a pas eu la possibilité
de le faire en partie parce qu'on nous
demande en rapport justement sur la
gouvernance et les les actions
régionales pour l'année prochaine et
donc on a préféré prendre le temps de
d'aller plus en profondeur sur cette
dimension mais c'est nul c'est pas du
tout une réflexion du manque ou de notre
appréciation du manque d'importance de
la ruralité et donc je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir soulevé le sujet la
raison pour laquelle on organise notre
travail justement avec un secteur
agricole émission bâtiment énergie et
industrie c'est que c'est la façon dont
les émissions sont reportées aux Nations
Unies et donc on a un cadre pour
analyser les émissions qui est basée sur
le cadre des Nations Unies et donc c'est
la seule raison pour laquelle on fait
notre rapport dans cette dans cette
articulation
sur le les l'adaptation concrètement ce
à quoi on s'attend c'est que les acteurs
qui prennent des décisions aujourd'hui à
tous niveaux
suivent justement une trajectoire de
réchauffement climatique qui est attendu
qui est la trajectoire de 4 de gris pour
la France donc c'est une trajectoire qui
pourrait être revenue revue à l'avenir
si on fait mieux mais avec les
politiques publiques actuelles c'est
malheureusement la trajectoire à
laquelle on s'attend avec des années
plus chaudes encore pour tenir compte de
la de la variété climatique et donc dans
les documents pardon dans les
documentations et les guides de
planification on peut du coup plutôt que
de regarder l'actuel pour par exemple
construire pour l'aménagement du
territoire en particulier on peut
regarder justement
quelle sera la trajectoire avec tous les
impacts climatiques qui vont avec il
faut aussi regarder le coup pour les
assurances en particulier mais le coût
aussi pour les développements et
l'exploitation future de de nous
aménagements peut-être Sylvain tu
pourras ajouter à la fin quelques
éléments si tu le souhaites
le plan du SGPA effectivement les 52
levier sont un processus important parce
que il démontre un certain niveau
d'opération
de la trajectoire du gouvernement et
donc c'est une avancée importante cette
année nous avons analysé du coup des
indicateurs que nous avions choisis nous
parmi ceux qui existaient dans la
stratégie nationale bas carbone cette
année on n'a pas encore pris la décision
de quelle stratégie on allait utiliser
parce que la SNBC est revisé elle est
pas encore publiée mais on espère
qu'elle sera effectivement du public au
moins le projet avant que les décisions
devront se prendre les décisions seront
prises et du coup on pourra décider à ce
moment-là mais effectivement c'est
vraiment important de regarder les
leviers et non pas seulement les
résultats parce que ce sont les leviers
qui nous permettent de dire si on fait
des actions qui sont structurellement
qui vont dans la bonne direction et au
niveau surtout
au niveau de est-ce que justement c'est
à nous d'arbitrer ou pas je pense que
c'est est-ce que c'est vous qui nous
avez épousé cette question donc le Haut
Conseil pour le climat est composé
d'experts sur soi
le climat comme moi-même climatologue
l'agriculture ou l'énergie et si on
social donc on n'est pas du tout là pour
prendre des décisions à la place du
gouvernement on est là pour faire des
recommandations pour que on atteigne les
objectifs climatiques et qu'on protège
l'ensemble de la société en France et au
niveau global c'est vraiment là c'est ça
notre rôle on a justement dans nos
recommandations on fait vraiment on
essaie très attention en tout cas on est
très très conscient de ne pas prescrire
les politiques publiques mais de donner
les options qui sont qui vont dans la
trajectoire ou qui entre dans la
trajectoire bas carbone c'est bien sûr
au gouvernement de prendre des décisions
qui va avec si le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas suivre certaines de nos
recommandations c'est pas du tout un
problème par contre le gouvernement doit
dire s'il ne suit pas certaines de nos
recommandations qu'est-ce qu'il fait
pour que ça marche donc c'est vraiment
ça le petit que on essaie vraiment très
très fort d'avoir des débats de
ressortir des propos neutres des propos
surtout indépendants et qui représentent
un consensus de l'ensemble du Haut
Conseil pour le climat
sur le CCAS donc il y a eu deux
questions sur le stockage et la capture
du carbone donc nous avons reçu cette
semaine une saisine du gouvernement
justement pour nous demander notre avis
sur le CCAS donc nous sommes en train de
d'élaborer un avis qui va inclure
justement une analyse déjà technique de
ce qui est possible en France mais aussi
plus loin de sa pertinence vue la
situation actuelle en particulier au
niveau des plus de carbone qui sont
moins forts que prévu maintenant si on
regarde les trajectoires actuelles sur
le CCUS donc dans les par exemple dans
les trajectoires des modèles globaux on
voit que il est utilisé vraiment
beaucoup il est dans pratiquement tous
les scénarios mais il n'est pas utilisé
pour remplacer les options qui existent
autre par exemple les ou même
bien sûr la sobriété mais il est utilisé
en plus pour déjà en termes de
transition et ensuite pour compenser les
émissions qui ne peuvent pas être
réduites ailleurs on a oui voilà donc je
peux pas tout de suite vous donner des
conclusions fermes par rapport à la vie
du Haut Conseil pour le climat par
contre je pourrais nous pourrons revenir
vers vous au moment de publication de
notre apport qui sera
mi-novembre normalement sur le nucléaire
merci de votre question donc le
nucléaire c'est effectivement une
énergie bas carbone qui est importante
en France parce que elle veut ça veut
dire que nous avons de l'électricité
baccarbonne en quantité en France donc
c'est pas le Haut Conseil pour le climat
n'a pas de de pignon sur la qualité de
de l'énergie utilisée
par contre il faut bien voir que pour
atteindre l'objectif 2030 on doit
déployer malgré tout ce qu'on fait pour
le nucléaire malgré le potentiel du
nouveau nucléaire y compris le nouveau
nucléaire pour les décennies futures le
déploiement du nucléaire c'est un
déploiement qui se fait très très
lentement et pour atteindre l'objectif
de 2030 on ne peut pas se passer d'un
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
en masse très très rapide accompagné
justement des mesures de sobriété donc
ce n'est pas un ou l'autre c'est
vraiment les deux énergies dans
l'ensemble d'une stratégie qui nous mène
jusqu'à la neutralité carbone avec le
mix énergétique que nous avons
actuellement en France
la question de l'intermittence elle est
très importante il faut bien sûr se
pencher sur le réseau électrique à
l'heure actuelle c'est ce que RTL fait à
l'heure actuelle donc il y a des
scénarios qui incluent plus ou moins
d'apport nucléaire pardon panucléaire
mais de
d'énergie renouvelable et
d'intermittence dans le système au sein
d'un pays qui est connecté avec les
autres pays européens ça aussi réduit
les tensions mais ça ne supprime pas le
besoin déjà de renforcer le réseau
électrique actuel et de développer
justement ces alternatives pour les
moments où on aura moins de production
électrique et donc de voir justement le
stockage qui est nécessaire et le
système de d'échange entre les pays qui
est nécessaire au niveau du GNL c'est
vraiment un sujet très très important
parce que avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie on a voulu diversifier les
sources d'énergie et de gaz
particulièrement en France et le GNL est
une un gaz à et source de gaz à effet de
serre très importantes et que il ne faut
pas que la France investisse dans des
trajectoires qui vont rendre ce latin de
la neutralité carbone très difficile et
c'est le cas du GNL donc les
développements dans ce système doivent
être le plus limité possible bien sûr
je vais laisser ma collègue parler
d'élevage mais je veux juste par contre
donner une toute petite note ici c'est
que bien sûr les les
agriculteurs ne sont pas les premiers
responsables les agriculteurs font leur
travail d'agriculteur et effectivement
quand il y a des pressions sur le monde
agricole en France il y a aussi des des
implications sur les importations qui
sont dues en partie oppressions ou en
partie simplement au marché plus large
et à l'offre alimentaire qui est
alimentée à la fois par la production en
France mais aussi par les importations
étrangères et du coup c'est bien il faut
vraiment bien parler de système
alimentaire quand on parle de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France mais je vais laisser Marion
parler de ça et aussi de la question sur
les sols s'il te plaît Marion
effet donc sur les importations comment
est-ce qu'on fait en réalité qui m'a
posé cette question par ici je pense
donc il y a des méthodes nous on produit
pas de données au conseil pour le climat
donc on utilise les données qui sont je
pense dans ce cas qui viennent du sdes
donc producteur de données sur justement
l'empreinte carbone donc ils ont
amélioré leur méthode de de
donner de production de données l'année
dernière si ma mémoire est bonne et on
regarde du coup à ce moment-là quel
produit sont importés d'où ils viennent
ou est-ce qu'ils sont assemblés et quel
est l'empreinte carbone de ces
différents produits et donc
effectivement on a de plus en plus
d'importations bien que la tendance à
l'augmentation elle est soit ralentie
soit stabilisée soit inversé dans les
dernières années mais que effectivement
les émissions associées aux importations
sont importantes que la France elle doit
s'en préoccuper plus on va vers la
neutralité carbone plus elle deviendront
importante et du coup ces évaluations et
un suivi de l'empreinte carbone doit se
faire en parallèle aux actions qui sont
faites sur la France
le levier majeur de la taille des
véhicules absolument on l'a soulevé dans
notre rapport c'est un levier qui
pourrait être inversé qui qui touche à
la fois les véhicules électriques et les
véhicules thermiques ce n'est plus le
cas maintenant où on peut prendre des
décisions économiques sans se soucier de
l'impact de l'impact qu'ils auront pour
la transition vers la neutralité carbone
Marion
merci alors vous avez tout à fait raison
sur plusieurs points que vous soulignez
oui les soldes de grandes cultures
s'appauvrissent en carbone et oui il y a
des méthodes pour réenrichir des
pratiques agricoles qui réenrichissent
les seuls agricoles le retournement des
prairies ça fait perdre du carbone
diminuer ça fait perdre du carbone et
donc il y a tout un plan dans le plan
qui a été présenté par le gouvernement
récemment donc comment recréer comment
recréer de l'agro comment encourager
l'agroforesterie comment éviter le
retournement de des prairies enfin tout
un ensemble de mesures qui sont
destinées à augmenter le stockage de
carbone dans les soldes alors sur
l'élevage ils nous ont pas attendu
malheureusement s'il y a des stockages
enfin si actuellement il y a diminution
du cheptel puisque
9,5% du nombre d'animaux en moins depuis
2016 entre 2016 et 2022 ce qui est quand
même très significatif ça n'est pas du
tout lié
aux préconisations climat mais c'est
malheureusement lié aux conditions
socio-économiques des exercices du
métier donc nous ce qu'on préconise dans
notre rapport c'est une modération de la
consommation de viande ça oui parce que
je veux dire c'est actuellement c'est
là-dessus qu'on doit jouer puisqu'on a
vu une réaugmentation de la condensation
de viande bovine et d'ailleurs largement
alimentée par les importations ce qui
est un peu absurde mais ce que nous
recommandons c'est
d'ailleurs il y a un plan filaire bovine
c'est faire en sorte que par kilo de
viande ou par litre de lait il y a une
diminution de l'empreinte gaz à effet de
serre et il y a tout une liste de choses
que les professionnels l'ont repéré
comme permettant de diminuer l'empreinte
de gaz à effet de serre donc
essentiellement du méthane comme vous le
savez un recouvrir les fossalisées la
génétiques d'alimentation enfin beaucoup
de pratiques qui peuvent être mises en
place progressivement et qui permettrait
de d'atténuer ces gaz à effet de serre
donc notre recommandation c'est un plan
d'ensemble pour l'évolution de la
filière dans le sens d'une filière qui
permette de réduire les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre tout en permettant une
vie
décente pour les agriculteurs
alors est-ce que je peux compléter par
le fait qu'on prépare en rapport sur
l'agriculture alimentation vous avez vu
que l'agriculture et l'alimentation
c'est quand même beaucoup de choses à
faire changer à la fois et
vraisemblablement on le publiera juste
avant la fin de l'année 2023 il est en
cours de chantier
juste un mot pour dire très concrètement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire en matière
d'adaptation à l'échelle locale qu'elle
soit urbaine ou rurale depuis le premier
plan national d'adaptation changement
climatique et ça a été enrichi avec le
deuxième il existe des outils en fait
qui mettent à disposition de tout un
chacun des entreprises des collectivités
des projections climatiques effectuées
par les climatologues et qui sont
travaillés par qui sont les mêmes que
celles qui sont trahis par les auteurs
du GIEC donc c'est par exemple à travers
le portail drias les futurs du climat où
on trouve les projections de l'Institut
Pierre Simon Laplace du CERFA axe de
Météo France qui sont à des résolutions
de 8 km sur la France métropolitaine
mais aussi pour certains outre-mer
aujourd'hui et ça va être enrichi très
prochainement à travers ces outils on
peut développer des ce qu'on appelle des
services climatiques qui permettent en
fait d'avoir un diagnostic des impacts
au premier niveau en diagnostic des
phénomènes physiques mais aussi des
impacts sur la sécheresse des sols par
exemple à l'échelle de 8 km sur le
métropole et donc directement permettre
de d'établir directement le lien avec
des activités et à partir de ce diagn
donc déjà de diagnostic de l'état
présent des vulnérabilités des activités
au changement climatiques actuelles on
se projette dans le futur on peut on
peut évaluer ces vulnérabilités
l'évolution des vulnérabilités dans le
futur et donc savoir quel est le niveau
de préparation nécessaire et donc les
besoins d'adaptation alors on a souligné
dans d'autres rapports 2023 les limites
les limites capacitaires en 2022 c'est
des choses qu'on retrouve en fait dans
les projections climatiques les limites
qui sont atteintes aujourd'hui si on
voit que la vulnérabilité augmente
demain c'est limite il va falloir les
repousser et donc c'est des besoins
d'adaptation le repousser ses limites
c'est les besoins d'adaptations
aujourd'hui dans presque tous les
secteurs on est capable d'avoir une
estimation à un premier niveau des
besoins d'adaptation aujourd'hui les
outils existent il s'agit de s'en saisir
en fait et ces outils ont été développés
depuis 2012-2013 pour les premiers et
sont accessibles alors ils
s'enrichissent par exemple des stations
de sports d'hiver aujourd'hui sont
capables de diagnostiquer jusqu'à quel
Horizont de temps l'exploitation de tel
versant de telles pi sur tel versant et
encore viable économiquement il y a cinq
ans on savait pas faire ça aujourd'hui
on sait le faire ce qui est important et
ce qu'on recommande nous c'est que tout
le monde s'en saisisse que tout le monde
soit conscient de s'ils vulnérabilité
pour pouvoir les traiter et investir à
bon escient c'est vraiment ça de
recommandations et c'est très concret ce
que je viens de dire
merci pour ces réponses très complètes
aux questions des collègues est-ce que
il y a une volonté de reposer des
questions des compléments pas de volonté
merci beaucoup nous retrouvons demain
matin à 9h non pas dans cette magnifique
salle mais dans la salle des affaires
économiques pour l'examen conjoint avec
cette même commission du rapport de la
mission d'information commune sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
nous nous retrouvons par contre dans
cette même salle à 15h demain pour
l'examen la proposition de loi relative
à la prévisibilité l'organisation des
services de la navigation aérienne en
cas de mouvement social et à
l'adéquation entre l'ampleur de la grève
et la réduction du trafic je vous jure
c'est pas moi qui ai choisi le titre
à demain merci beaucoup